we already know how to calculate cell
potential when the reactants and
products are in their standard states
however what if that's not the case we
can find cell potential when reactants
and products are not in their standard
states by using the nernst equation
which is shown here and we're going to
call that cell potential the
instantaneous cell potential
e cell is the instantaneous cell
potential the cell potential or voltage
at a specific moment in time e naught of
the cell is the standard cell potential
this is the cell potential when the
reactants and products are in their
standard states
r is the ideal gas constant t is the
temperature n is the number of electrons
transferred in the redox reaction f is
faraday's constant
and q is the reaction quotient so this
is one way to write the nernst equation
and let's compare this form of the
nernst equation to a simplified form
in the simplified form of the nernst
equation e of the cell is equal to e
naught of the cell minus
0.0592 volts divided by n times the log
of the reaction quotient q
so going back to the first form of the
nernst equation if we assume the
temperature is 25 degrees celsius or 298
kelvin we multiply that by the ideal gas
constant divide that by faraday's
constant and if we're changing natural
log to log
then we end up with this with this form
for the bottom equation 0.0592 volts
divided by n times the log of q for this
second term of the nernst equation you
can use the nernst equation to
quantitatively calculate the exact
voltage at a specific moment in time
however we're going to try to think
about the nernst equation from a
qualitative point of view
let's use the nernst equation to think
about the instantaneous
cell potential for a zinc copper cell
and we're going to look at a few
different situations
in a zinc copper cell solid zinc is
oxidized to zinc two plus ions and
copper two plus ions are reduced to form
solid copper
the standard cell potential for the zinc
copper cell at 25 degrees celsius is
equal to positive 1.10 volts and our
goal is to find the cell potential at
the moment of time when the
concentration of copper two plus ions is
equal to one point zero molar and the
concentration of zinc two plus ions in
solution is also equal to one point zero
molar
to find the instantaneous cell potential
we're going to use the simplified form
of the nernst equation e naught of the
cell is equal to positive 1.10 volts
next let's think about n the number of
electrons transferred in the redox
reaction so looking at our equation here
solid zinc going to zinc two plus is
loss of two electrons and copper two
plus going to solid copper is a gain of
two electrons so two electrons were
transferred and n is equal to two
so i've gone ahead and made n equal to
two in our equation
next we need to think about the reaction
quotient q q has the same form as the
equilibrium constant expression so if we
think about the balanced equation
remember pure solids are left out of
equilibrium constant expressions so it
would be the concentration of products
over the concentration of reactants and
therefore q is equal to the
concentration of zinc two plus ions
divided by the concentration of copper
two plus ions
because our goal is to find the
instantaneous cell potential when the
concentrations are both equal to one
molar q is equal to one divided by one
so q is equal to one
and the log of one is equal to zero
therefore this entire second term in the
nernst equation is equal to zero
which means the instantaneous cell
potential is equal to the standard cell
potential so the instantaneous cell
potential is equal to positive
1.10 volts
and this answer makes a lot of sense
because standard state for solutions is
a one molar concentration therefore the
instantaneous cell potential
is equal to the standard cell potential
at this moment in time
next let's think about the instantaneous
cell potential when the concentration of
copper two plus ions is equal to 10.0
molar and the concentration of zinc two
plus ions is equal to 1.0 molar
the standard cell potential at 25
degrees celsius is still equal to
positive 1.10 volts
and n is still equal to 2 so we need to
think about the reaction quotient q at
this moment in time
the concentration of zinc two plus ions
is equal to 1.0 molar so we plug that in
and the concentration of copper two plus
ions is equal to 10.0 molar
so at this moment in time q is less than
one
the log of a number less than 1 is
negative
therefore this second term would be
negative or less than 0.
and since we are subtracting a negative
number we would actually be adding that
value to the standard cell potential
which means that the instantaneous cell
potential will be greater than the
standard cell potential and if you went
ahead and calculated the instantaneous
cell potential with the nernst equation
you would find it's equal to positive
1.13 volts which is greater than
positive 1.10 volts
next let's think about the instantaneous
cell potential when the concentration of
copper two plus ions is equal to one
point zero molar and the concentration
of zinc two plus ions is equal to ten
point zero molar going to the nernst
equation the standard cell potential is
still positive one point one zero volts
and n is still equal to two so next we
think about the reaction quotient q at
this moment in time the concentration of
zinc two plus ions is equal to ten point
zero molar and the concentration of
copper two plus ions is equal to one
point zero molar so at this moment in
time q
is greater than one
the log of a number greater than one is
positive therefore the second term in
our equation will be positive or greater
than zero
and because we are subtracting a
positive number we would be subtracting
a value from the standard cell potential
which means that the instantaneous cell
potential will be less than the standard
cell potential and if you plug the
numbers into the nernst equation you
would find that the instantaneous cell
potential is equal to positive
1.07 volts which is less than the
standard cell voltage of 1.10 volts
we just saw that at the moment in time
when the concentration of copper two
plus sines is equal to 1.0 molar and the
concentration of zinc two plus ions is
equal to 10.0 molar the instantaneous
cell potential is equal to positive 1.07
volts let's use this moment in time as a
starting point and let's think about
what happens to the instantaneous cell
potential as the reaction progresses
remember that the instantaneous cell
potential is related to the
instantaneous change in free energy
delta g by this equation delta g is
equal to negative nfe
because we have a positive value for the
instantaneous cell potential if we plug
in a positive value into our equation
because of the negative sign in the
equation we would get a negative sign
for delta g
and when delta g is negative the
reaction is thermodynamically favored
which means the reactants will turn into
products and as the reactants turn into
products the concentration of zinc two
plus ions will increase and the
concentration of copper two plus ions
will decrease
and think about what that does to the
reaction quotient q there would be an
increase in the concentration of zinc
two plus ions and a decrease in the
concentration of copper two plus ions so
q would no longer be equal to 10.0 over
1.0 we would see an increase in q as the
reactants turn into the products
an increased value of q
means that the second term in the nernst
equation will be a larger positive
number so if we subtract a larger
positive number than we did in the
previous example from the standard cell
potential we would get a lower
instantaneous cell potential than
positive 1.07 volts so what the nernst
equation tells us is as the reaction
goes to the right there's an increase in
q and as q increases there's a decrease
in the instantaneous cell potential
so we've just seen as the reaction goes
to the right that's an increase in q and
according to the nernst equation that's
a decrease in the instantaneous cell
potential and therefore the
instantaneous cell potential would
decrease from 1.07 volts however the
voltage would still be positive which
means that delta g would still be
negative which means the reaction is
still thermodynamically favored and so
this keeps happening as the reaction
goes to the right q keeps increasing and
the instantaneous cell potential keeps
decreasing so we had started out a
positive 1.07 volts and we saw that that
had decreased and it keeps on decreasing
keeps on decreasing eventually the
instantaneous cell potential will go to
zero volts and when the voltage goes to
0 if you plug in 0 into our equation
delta g is equal to 0. and when delta g
is equal to 0 the reaction is at
equilibrium and the reaction quotient q
is equal to the equilibrium constant k
so if you were to plug in the
equilibrium constant k in for q you
would find that this entire second term
would be equal to positive 1.10 volts
and cancel out the standard cell
potential giving an instantaneous
potential of zero volts
so if we think about our zinc copper
cell as a battery when the reaction
reaches equilibrium the voltage is equal
to zero and the battery is dead
let's do a quick summary of what we've
learned from the nernst equation so this
is the simplified form which is valid at
25 degrees celsius when q is equal to 1
the instantaneous cell potential is
equal to the standard cell potential
when q is greater than one the
instantaneous cell potential is less
than the standard cell potential when q
is less than one the instantaneous cell
potential is greater than the standard
cell potential
and when q is equal to the equilibrium
constant k
the instantaneous cell potential is
equal to zero volts when q is equal to k
and the potential is equal to zero the
reaction is at equilibrium
however for these first three situations
q is not equal to k and the
instantaneous cell voltage is not equal
to zero therefore the reaction is not at
equilibrium